we are now entering the Golden Age of
research in black hole physics they
could be the key to understanding the
birth of the universe is formation and
then it's death
black holes really represented one sense
the frontier of modern astronomy they're
changing our ideas about how galaxies
form and indeed how the universe works
their power comes from one of the
primary forces in nature gravity
I teach astronomy we teach our students
that the fundamental principle of
gravity is gravity sucks gravity keeps
our feet on the ground and our planet
orbiting around the Sun but in a black
hole the force of gravity is off the
charts so strong it sucks in anything
nearby it can even bend the light from
distant stars
and if that light gets too close the
black hole swallows it think of it like
this imagine a black hole as a waterfall
gravity is the river flowing toward the
falls and a beam of light the kayak
upriver from the waterfall the current
is weak the kayaker can paddle against
it and get away but closer to the
waterfall the current is stronger and
the kayaker struggles to escape
the edge of the waterfall is like the
edge of a black hole
no matter how strong the kayaker is he's
going down it's the same in space the
way black holes are really devastating
is because when you get close to them
the gravity gets super strong
so strong that they eat light that's why
black holes are black